Well let's see, to calculate mg, we multiply m, which is 10 kg by g which is 10 m/s².
1010 is a 100 N. Before we go to Fn, let's do the wall first.
If the right word force is 86.6 N and the object isn't accelerating,
well the left word force must be bouncing it exactly.
These two forces are the only horizontal forces that must be exactly equal. So this is 86.6 N.
We also know that for opposite that rests, forces up must bounce forces down
and for us that means that the normal force that goes up must equal not just mg, which goes down,
but also mg + FRy.
Those are the two downward forces and that gives me a value of 150 N.
This was a very tricky problem, if you follow along, you're doing great
and if not go back and watch again